[Musique]
merci c'est le printemps on a 20 ans le
cœur et le moteur battent gment droit
devant nous sans savoir où n filons
comme des fous car aujourd'hui tout est
permis dans une auto qu'on est bien
entre amis alors chantons sur tous les
temps le bonheur d'être garçon avoir un
bon copain voilà ce qu' VI a de me MEUR
au monde
car un bon copain c'est plus fidèle
qu'une
blonde
unit main dans la
main à chaque
seconde de ses chagrins quand on possède
un bon
copain les dou aveux des amoureux
avouonsle maintenant ces vieux jeux sexe
charmant tellon serment ne sont que des
boniments point de baiser pour se griser
sur une route il suffit de gazé le grand
amour ça dure un jour l'amitié dure
toujours
avoir un bon copain voilà ce qu'il VI
meilleur au
[Musique]
monde un bon copain c'est plus fidèle
qu'une
blonde
punit main dans la main
à chaque
seconde R de ces chagrins quand on
possède un bon
copain rit de ses chagrin quand on
[Musique]
copain